クソーーーーーーー！！！！！
もう嫌だ！！！！！
。。。。。。。
はじめしゃちょーです…
あのあのあのあのですね
最近動画でよく言ってると思うんですけども
花粉症が本当に限界に近くて
いよいよ生活することが不可能になってきました
じゃあ薬のめばいいじゃんということで
なんか市販の薬とか
鼻水止めとかめっちゃ飲んでるんですけども
いまいち効きません
じゃあじゃあ病院行けよって話なんですけども
花粉症治したいから耳鼻科の方に連絡したら
あのディズニーランド並みに待ち時間がありますって言われて
ってことでもうどうしようもすることができません
ちなみに僕の症状は目と鼻と口です
鼻が詰まりこの鼻水がなんか口にきてﾌﾞｫｫｫﾛﾛﾛってなって
目もなんかｶｻｶｻｶｻ～ｶｲｶｲｶｲ～ってなってもう
わぁーーーーーい！！！！！
どうすればいいんだよぉぉおお！！！！
ということでどうすればいいのか分かんないのでちょっとネットで調べてみました
なんかね結局ね、なんか生活とかも大事なんですけども
食べ物がすごい大事らしいんですよ
腸内環境が良くなるだけで結構花粉症の症状が緩和されるって聞いたことがあるんで
最近無駄にヨーグルトとか食ってます
良くなったかは分かりませんがね！！！
という訳で花粉に良い食べ物をネットで調べてみました
まず腸内環境を整えることが大事らしいです
ヨーグルト、いいですよ、多分。
あとお味噌！お味噌もなんかいいらしいです
発酵食品は善玉菌である乳酸菌やビフィズス菌が入ってるんで
発酵してりゃあええみたいなとこあるらしいですよ
そしてあとしめ鯖！
花粉症の原因はヒスタミンというアレルギー物質らしいです
DHA、ドコサヘキサエン酸、エイコサペンタエン酸はそのヒスタミンというアレルギー物質の働きを抑える力があるらしいです
めっちゃいいやん！
発酵食品の仲間でキムチも効くらしいです
そしてあとごま油もいいらしいです
これも花粉のアレルギー症状を抑える何か入ってるらしいです
おなじく発酵仲間で納豆、あとごぼうときなこもいいらしいです
これ何でかと言いますと
食物繊維がたくさん入ってるんで善玉菌をこう増やす作用があるらしいです
あとぬか漬けも発酵食品です
そして最後！チョコレートも花粉にちょっといいらしいです
これも実は発酵食品なんだ！カカオを発酵させて作られてるらしいですね
はい、という訳でですね
この中で僕が好き好んで食べれると言ったらもう
ぐらいなんですよ
（笑い）
というわけでこんなのチマチマ食ってても時間がもったいねぇ！ということで
これをひと集めに合体させたら
最強に花粉に強い料理ができるんじゃないかと思いまして
今回はこれらを合わせて
花粉に最も効く素晴らしい料理を作ってみようと思います
天才でしょう？
＠&＊？#￥％(聞き取り不可能)
ハハハハハ！
というわけで早速
レッツクッキング！
はい皆さん、というわけではじめ先生だよ～
早速作っていきましょうね～
まず先に言っておきましょう、間違いなく
というわけで少量作ってみることにしましょう
こちらのフラスコくらいのサイズ感で作っていきましょう
もう一度言っておきます、間違いなくクソ不味いです
では、お料理開始！
では現状入れれそうな食材からどんどん入れていきましょう
ではまずごま油をとりあえず入れていきましょう
では続いてキムチ入れていきます
おわぁぁぁーーー
なんかすげー鼻がスースーするんだよね
キムチは個人的に結構有効な気がするんですよね
よし入った！
はい、入りました！
続いてきなこ入れていきましょう
あーーー全部落ちました
もう取り止めのつかないことになってきたぞこれ
続いてチョコレート入れましょう
チョコレートは細かく切り刻んで入れます
スゥーーー（口から出そうになったチョコを吸う音）
ﾄﾝﾄﾝﾄﾝ…（チョコを刻む音）
ではチョコを入れていきまーす
＃＄％＆‘＊（聞き取り不可能）
やっぱ地味にねー、ヨーグルトとかが一番体にいい気がすんだよね
もうこれでええやん
では入れさせていただきます
ううぉあーーー
すごいことになってきました
さぁどんどん減って参りました
続いての食材は
ぬ、ぬか、ぬか、ぬかです
分からないまま買ったんですけど多分発酵してればいいと思います
よしよしよしよしはいはいはいはい
入りました！！
お塩ーーー！！！
味噌ーーー！！！
ダメ花粉でもう頭が回らなくてねーもう
味噌と塩の違いも分からない
鼻が詰まってて味が分かりません
入れます
よーし続いては納豆です
もう何でも入れていきます
納豆ってもうなんか体にいいっていうイメージしかないんですよね
ほっ！
よしよしよしいいんじゃないでしょうか
入れます
うん、うぅぉーー、ううぉーー
ｽﾞﾙﾙﾙ（納豆を食べる音）
うめぇ
では続けてえー鯖です、鯖入れていきます
もーねー、鯖こん中に入れる必要ないと思うんだー
てか僕の目標は味とかじゃなくー
花粉を治す食べ物を作ることなんでー
まあしゃーなし入れましょう
も、もうやばいもうやばいもうやばい
じゃあ最後にごぼうです
大事な根菜類です
いやでも入ってるものだけ聞くとほんとに体によさそうな気がするんですよね
ｶﾝｶﾝｺﾝｶﾝｶﾝｺﾝｶﾝ（ごぼうを刻む音）
まあいい感じに刻んどきました
多分これで大丈夫だと思います
はいというわけで全ての食材が混ざり終わりました、こちらです
もうもうやばい、もう、もうもうやばい、もうやばいです
ですが皆さん、大事なのは味ではございません
果たしてこれが花粉症に効くのかどうか
早速試してみたいと思います
うわー、グロいけど混ぜ…おぉー混ぜるしかないです、混ぜましょう
あっ！うわっ！まっやっやばい！
う”わぁーーー！！！
はい！！！！！
というわけでできました
これが恐らく最も花粉に効くであろう史上最強の料理でございます
味は知りません、てかもう不味いの確定してます、よろしくお願いします
もうお薬です、お薬
う”おおええぇぇ
もうお薬と思って僕開発したんで
なんか豚汁の匂いがしますね
どっから豚（とん）が出てきたんだ？
さあ、というわけで…
ﾊｧ…（ため息）
早速飲んでみようと思います
味が不味いのはもう知ってんだよ
効果です、効果、大事なのは
飲んでみようと思います、いただきます
ﾊｧ、ﾊｧ
ｳﾞｪｰｰｰｰ!!!!!
乾杯！！！！！
ﾊｰｰｰｰｰ!!!!!
わ、分かった、待って、わ、待って、わ、あぁ待って！あ、あぁーやばい！あ、もう
あ”ぁ！あ”、あ”、あ”
あ↑あ↓あ↑あ～はぁはぁはぁ～はぁはぁはぁ
うぅーーー！！！
食べましたーーー！！！
やばいやばいやばいびっくりびっくり
まあまあ、まあまあ味から言いましょう
あの…予想通りクソ不味かったです
なんかそのなんか魚とか、魚とか納豆のそのぬめりけがもうｳｪﾙﾚﾚってなってて
生臭さになんか味噌の変な、なんかしょっぱさも混ざりつつ
と思ったらヨーグルトのまろやかみが来たと思ったらチョコレートの甘みが襲い掛って来
歯ごたえが結構ヌルヌルしてるなと思ったらごぼうのシャキシャキ感が襲い掛かって
もう混沌…としていましたね
ごちそうさまでした
肝心な効果なんですけども
花粉が…
ﾊｧｯｸｼｮﾝ！
ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑　ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑
ﾃｰﾃﾚﾚﾃｰﾚｰ♪　ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰﾃﾚﾚﾃｰﾚｰ♪
ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰﾃｰﾚﾚ　ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰﾚｰﾚｰ♪
ﾃﾃﾃﾃﾝ♪